[Applause]
please welcome drew carey
how are you doing hi drew i totally
cannot believe i'm doing this with you
yeah it's crazy you know i just want to
say just because we have the same name
i've always wanted to meet you
and it's weird you know when you see
other drews you're like oh and then
i've met you know i know jim carrey and
i've met
mariah carey so i got the carries out of
the way
and i have to meet drew brees still but
you know meeting you is great
my dossier for you i kept going i've
never done that why do they keep saying
drew
and i'm like i did the same thing i was
talking to jen your producer
and she was like and then drew's gonna
do it i was like whoa you gotta use some
code word
or something because that's i was like
i've never been to that place why are
they saying oh it's for
yes it's true he's been there not me
um okay so i can't believe i'm about to
launch into this but
it's game show week so i grew up right
down the block
almost from the cbs studios where you
film prices right
and that that was like my thing growing
up was watching the prices right
and it's my favorite game show and it
was like
my companion growing up so
will you fulfill a fantasy for me with
me and we could play the prices right
sure
[Laughter]
this is so cool all right we're going to
play a game that's been a fan favorite
since
1972. uh i know the show
became a one-hour show in 1975 which is
the year i was born from a half an hour
show
and i think that's like when the big
wheel came in right
right in 75 the year i was born
wow wow that was my first year in
college
seriously yeah i graduated high school
in 75 i should have graduated in 76
but i skipped my senior year so i
graduated in 75.
you look too young to have graduated in
75. god bless you here i am with a great
beard
and he's saying that i was like you're
messing with me right
no you look good um okay this game has
been a fan favorite since 1972 it's the
clock
game yeah
[Music]
can you explain the rules of the clock
game drew
sure really quickly uh there's two
prizes that we're playing for just in
the special edition of the clock game
here
um you have 30 seconds to give us the
price the exact price
of two different prizes so you're gonna
give me what you the price that you
think
it is then i know the real price right
here and i'm going to tell you whether
the actual price is higher or lower than
what you just said
okay this is so fun and one of our lucky
vfs will win
each prize if i guess correctly plus an
extra thousand dollars if i get them
both
in 30 seconds let's meet our vff jenna
hi jenna hi so nice to virtually meet
you
nice to meet you i'm uh from new jersey
i love the prices right it's my favorite
game ever
ever and i tape the show every day
because my daughters want to watch it
when they come home from school so we
all watch together
and the clock game is one of our
favorites so this is amazing oh perfect
this is gonna be great
i can't wait you got this drew okay
thank you all right i'm gonna hook in
with drew jenna let's see what the two
prizes are
that you can win luckily i have
ross matthew here as our prize model
to showcase the items rise
yeah oh come on you brought it
i know right okay ross you look
beautiful
jenna so do you okay here we go first up
is our ecovax debot vacuuming and
mopping robot
and our second price is a brand new
washer and dryer
this is major i'm salivating right now
and also we're gonna i think we're gonna
steal your idea of unveiling with the
uh like a magician because that looked
really great hey
i am reading a little magician aren't i
just a little bit i didn't mean to
i love it okay i have no idea what the
actual retail prices of any of these
prizes are
so i'm ready to go you're a celebrity
how would you know
by the way my washer dryer is broken so
i'm literally like coveting so i'm like
oh
those are really nice um okay so
here we go are we ready to play let's
play
yeah um okay all right so
uh we're playing for the vacuum robot
first okay and uh you have 30 seconds to
give us the price
both what you're going to do is like
just like i said before tell me what you
think the price is i'll tell you where
they need to go higher or lower
we're going to show the audience at home
the price on their screen but you're not
going to be able to see it
all right and uh whenever you start the
clock's going to start 500
higher 6.75
quicker higher 800
lower 750
lower 700.
[Applause]
well how much time do we have left
13 seconds 13 seconds plenty of time
okay all right here we go here we go
okay ready and you
this next one not only does she get the
washer and dryer but she gets the extra
thousand dollars as the butterfly but if
you don't get this
she doesn't get the washing dryer and
she won't get the extra thousand dollars
oh gosh but don't get nervous okay here
we go
okay ready as you start talking the
clock's gonna start one thousand dollars
higher fifteen hundred dollars
higher seventeen hundred dollars
a lawyer
yes
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh good that's what we wanted to do we
wanted to make you cry jenna
you're both amazing oh amazing
thank you oh jenna congratulations thank
you so much
oh i really had like a very nervous
stomach
okay thank you jenna ross and drew
thank you for playing this is jenna and
i just got our fantasies realized
you